[Music]
in cheating the system knows I don't
understand what it was like in fuzzy
lizards news I don't know I think we're
hitting that hour right now that's true
it's that our friends in know I'm
pushing my cheekbones oh did they get
sore taking news days always kids know
nothing it's sore it's just a good
feeling don't you know why it is would
you do that too but you also whenever I
say like Jim Jean the system news to
foes was like oh no I know what you're
doing all day I'm like damn dude you're
working those things out how do you move
the cheese like that well you did this
it's a tip tip mug what's it taste like
you know when you're mugging no tell me
show me yeah I was like all right
submitted by Mason from Toronto hello
mason jar an ex-cop rigged the
McDonald's Monopoly game installed
millions of dollars over a decade that's
Joe they're actually so Ben Affleck and
Matt Damon are trying to make the movie
I danced in this is in Boston that's
gonna be tight they love [ __ ] Boston
love on they they put that Boston you
rigged a man monopoly game boardwalk
Park Place Danny you're asked it's a
question I should know and I Georgia
Georgia Oh interesting
oh no wait yeah why are they all over it
it's not it's okay don't worry about it
don't worry about it doesn't matter okay
just to let you guys know the people are
watching just to let you know this is a
really cool juicy long story so I
suggest you guys click on the link and
read it for yourself okay we don't want
them to leave this chat oh no no no
don't sit we're gonna be great
I'll show you watch this video come on
look bark take it away
go bar cool bar free a man a policeman
the biggest of the monopolies for 10
years job take it go Joe I don't know if
this is a good idea to do this to make
darkness okay now I'm gonna take it okay
this probably is Mexican guys huh all
right so this whole story revolves
around Jerome uncle Jerry Jacobson so he
stole more than 24 million dollars in
cash and prizes from McDonald's the
McDonald's Monopoly a me for millions
the integrity the game has been forever
damaged dude and has he been I knew
nobody won that [ __ ] the policeman the
whole time no so he was a cop early in
his life and he retired he got injured
and then so he retired and then he ended
up getting a job at this a private
security officer at the printing company
and he would be the one to oversee the
printing of the Makaha so he would take
one and hold it pick another one you
think it was a conflict of interest cuz
he worked there and then he was winning
or they never checked it he wasn't the
one winning Oh smart where people around
him with there was people around him
winning but the way they set it up is
they would fly or like drive to other
states set up like fake address like no
people from all these different states
that's genius
that's good 24 million you can spread
that around with friends and family and
[ __ ] yeah he's [ __ ] smart whenever
they would fill out the form that they
won or whatever then they wouldn't be
living near hammers they didn't know him
or whatever could be they would get
distant friends and just to clarify he
was part of the printing process that
was initially so initially he was
working for the printing company but
then and like this dude apparently he
was like super strict you would check
people's shoes to make sure they sneaked
any any of these game pieces but
later on he started working for the
marketing company that hired that
printing company so then he ended up
being in charge of those winning pieces
and he was tasked to distribute them to
factories all over the place - he would
pocket he would pocket some of these
that's like getting an assassin a
license to kill yeah yeah could do
whatever you want so he said that he
noticed that the game was flawed because
there was just one instance where there
was a winning like a random selection
computer randomized selection of a
winner in Canada and then some of his
higher-ups were like oh it's in Canada
no no no change it took somewhere else
ever like comment that Canadians illegal
did never give Canada a winning thing
why they think Canada huh it's a
violation dude you can do it I don't
know but apparently that's what he
claimed so that's when he saw it in his
eyes like well this game is already
rigged so what like why can't I get a
piece of it - I love justifying crime so
he did this from 1989 to 2001 this is a
huge story in that time he kept working
1989 2001 yeah they would do that shifts
is 89 Wow as a kid they had monopoly
every one of these [ __ ] who's
been winning it's been a joke well from
89 to 2001 Danielle's been the same
person whose entire time well the same
person behind it you know I'm a [ __ ]
french fries and drinks I bought oh my
god I got ripped off every time you come
on jakey news you find some new [ __ ]
that like ruins your past what was the
other thing quite a few things ruin my
past you it's hard to beat an arrow no
no other method didn't pull out his ribs
it's like a nose tell me about it that
[ __ ] makes me so sound I think don't
bring that one up you know compound
these things you know what people
started doing it was [ __ ] genius so
people on eBay would team up their
pieces together oh they'll know which
ones were the winning pieces so bill
charged that one to be like $15,000 or
whatever those are rare one yeah I just
got like you get french fries you get
another like free french
that you I was happy about that I just
thought you played by the friggin rules
and maybe one day you'll win because you
had integrity wrong
I always got free drinks or fries yeah
well guess what that's McDonald spitting
in your mouth isn't that great here's
something you already don't want yeah
that was genius of them because you
can't just have fries like you have to
buy either burger or drink to go echo
out the truth extra bulk you know there
were super smart too so those super rare
pieces that you need it like I think you
would have to collect three of them
right so the two were super common but
that last third one I think they would
only throw in two pieces for the whole
country so it would be like super could
have been thrown away no so what he
would do is he would save those pieces
and then throw in like a regular old
piece to distribute these because he
would go to the actual factories and he
would be the one in charge to distribute
these like instant win tickets he
developed this entire like crime Network
he'd started working with these mobsters
with psychic strip club owners convicts
drug traffickers I kick strip club
owners know the combination was just
interesting oh wow yeah let me read your
[ __ ] fortunes like hang on I predict
they're gonna want bottle service over
there on table - yeah how she always
know that's like the ghetto part of
Vegas where they're dealing cards
there's also stripper behind you yeah
like you mean just that's just plain a
Hollywood hotel my friend yeah you
probably would have kept getting away
with it but someone betrayed him because
the FBI got an anonymous tip saying that
winners paid uncle Jerry for stolen game
pieces uncle Jerry because that's what
they were called like the mobster dude
would call him uncle during that's how
you got the name so then after an
investigation the FBI arrested Jerry in
the summer of 2001 and with a [ __ ] ton
of evidence because they held actually
mcdonald's didn't want to do like that
last
Monopoly game of that year they were
planning on not doing it but then the
FBI
like told him like we really need we
need to sting
so they set up like a whole sting around
so this is a [ __ ] movie it's a dope
movie this was huge news at that time
but no one remembers it because the day
of like the first day of the court like
when the court thing was gonna start one
day before 9/11 oh did 9/11 so that they
could cover up the mcdonalds game to
keep the billions of dollars flowing I
[ __ ] knew it I've been saying it for
years I've been seeing this for a long
time you guys know that yeah yeah we've
known you for that long that's true
that's right I'm telling you dude to
cover up a 24 million heist two things
happen to that time so it worked out in
their favor
Gary Condit the congressman who was
suspected to have killed his intern
Chandra Levy who disappeared yeah they
were having an affair
guess what happened the next
[ __ ] day right 11 9/11
terrorist attacks do things together we
started one the Middle East everyone
makes money and McDonald's makes money I
wonder if they did this every year
that's kind of greedy it's making
millions of dollars out a bit like this
year someone else can win no dude I've
been like one time and you're good you
walk away clean he's working with
mobsters like racketeering and Stephanie
create like the whole thing I wonder why
he got he started dipping in with
mobsters at that job that he had he
would find business cars all over the
country he would have five-star meals
everywhere he would he was already
living life of a king oh and then he did
this on top of it that's why it's like
extra gravy
that's pretty greedy yeah I'm not even
like this is cool like when I heard that
I'm like I hate you no this is cool this
is cool I mean the heist is cool it's
super cool but I like the story of a
person that's been down and out that
just had to do it like Walter White you
know like like he just had to do it cuz
he had to pay for his cancer stuff give
it I like the FBI tip where they it's
like it's like check boardwalk Park
Place that's all I can say it's like
they're gonna [ __ ] kill me I can't
say more you know I mean like I love
that [ __ ] the states with what they're
talking
it's so don't got all the [ __ ]
railroads can't park here I have to go
to jail
simple thimble check the free parking I
pass go so we got a so if you signed a
confession and agreed to pay twelve
point five million dollars in
restitution he was sentenced to 37
months in jail
he's now 76 years old and living a quiet
life in Georgia I bet you hit a lot of
[ __ ] money it's always nothing
you 76 he looks pretty good for 76 so
you want white-collar crime there's the
worst sentencing in the world it was
kind of funny too so that mobster he
started working with Gerry Colombo he's
such a mobster named Gerry come over
Mike pick him up so he won a car and he
agreed to come out on a commercial
because a lot of these winner like polio
life owners they would do these
McDonalds commercials where they would
show you know the public like hey I won
this and I won that so he came out in
this commercial oh my god you know I
want this body wipe Oh check it out I
won this 100% legit this is completely
legitimate [ __ ] dude that's great he
died Gerry Colombo Florida I love it he
died before all this came to light so he
didn't face justice for all this [ __ ] oh
he did cuz he's dead so the string of
people that of the whole network got
[ __ ] right I bet you they got a mo
Rico that's when you use Rico yeah this
story is really juicy when you read it
but we're still pretty good
okay the case take it away go case
coffee yeah yeah I just want to change
the oriental Avenue thing go to the
beach ching chong Lin
yeah ching ching chong road
[Music]
you